yeah okay so I had spent now one hour
not to discuss one constraint no from
Boris your apology no try to try
variability I want to also cover some
other constraints no from the data and
now I have to do it much faster than
because it is have four different
constraints so we had heard a lot now
about diversity of neurons and synapses
and this is something which kills at
least the simple models for Boltzmann
machine like sampling the spiking
neurons there then also I think we need
also to take erino data into account
nowadays when people can record from
hundreds and thousands of neurons by the
animal carries out the computation and
so this point two different types of
neural network computation then is
commonly considered I want to discuss
also some aspects of synaptic plasticity
which haven't been discussed and also
that neuro codes tend to drift at least
in higher cortical areas which also may
change your perspective of neural coding
versus new computation then and
altogether I think I view this no I can
view this as constraints from the data
but you can also view this as clue snow
you want to discover how P and s work
and so this give you clues know what are
essential features apparently of these
computations in political networks of
neurons so concerning diversity now we
have seen a lot then this is just one
slide here from the Allen Institute
database they each know kind of no line
here reflects one measurement of a
neuron then so this for mouse this from
humans and so for example this
adaptation index which measures know how
much the firing of a neuron slows down
if you give it a constant input current
this is the average firing rate and some
other membrane time constant and you see
about every neuron has a different
profile in terms of this
electrophysiology measurements than
right and so this is something which now
again
no gives us a constraint for example
when you want to reduce noise by
duplicating neurons or sub computations
right because duplicating may be
difficult if you don't get the same kind
of copy of a neuron again then and I
think for me kind of know about the
particular challenge is also not to take
short-term plasticity of synapse into
account I think no I don't mention this
yesterday no this is also documented in
the Institute database so this shorter
plasticity should not be confused with
long term plasticity learning it's
simply an effect of synapses on the
timescale below a second typically which
means that if you send this spike train
to a kind of the spike train comes from
the presynaptic neuron and then if you
look at the amplitudes of postsynaptic
epsps then then they tend to change then
when you have a sequence of spikes some
of the synapses are facilitating so they
become larger
maybe you three or four times larger
other ones depress they become smaller
and then they're all kinds of mixtures
of these two things so in the literature
neurophysiology know typically women are
very often users know this model from
macrame doll the one uses three
parameters you DNF to characterize this
kind of short-term plasticity of
synapses and when you look now here now
in the three-dimensional space UDF of
note kind of this each dot is one
synapse there one measured synapse and
you see hardly any two neurons have
exactly the same short-term plasticity
there so and so but you still see
clusters of neurons and so recording at
least two the findings of macrame died
now when you have a particular type of
pre and postsynaptic neuron is typically
nature has chose a particular type of
short-term plasticity and particularly
no connections from n to inhibitor no
ones tend to be facilitating so when for
example bursts come through they become
larger and larger the outputs Barris nor
the connections between excited neurons
they tend to be depressing
which means it's very hard to do any
computations term of firing rates
because if you want to communicate a big
fine right now
then after viral simply shuts down the
synapse right it no longer transmits
this then and so therefore it's a
history dependence of a synapse which no
it's not taking to account usually by
modulus and you know I think exciting
open question is now how does nature
possibly benefit from this and I think
it forces us to think also in terms of
computations not in terms of inputs
being vectors of numbers of values and
outputs being another better output but
really in terms of computations on time
series so this is just you know one
cartoon now one spike trends no emitted
by one neuron it's ended here to a
facilitating synapse and you see it goes
it goes up and then it locate the Kazon
goes up this is another too depressing
synapse so therefore a neuron can
actually know then therefore send
different no kind of time serious
messages to other postsynaptic neurons
then
as I mentioned I think no one I think
strong implication of taking this into
account is I think for theoreticians no
computation kind of it becomes very hard
now to take any artificial neural
network computation or any kind of
boolean circuit or any circuit we like
in computer science and implemented in
one way or another with a model for B&N
then as soon as you put in this
depressing synapses between excited
neurons probably this model no longer is
going to work them right so therefore
there's something wrong then either no
nature has chosen different
architectures or no this data are wrong
then right but we kind of just no really
duplicate no okay computation
architectures from computer science
given this effect them and also no one
other kind of no effect is important
because in many computation series one
wants to do subtraction say no you have
predicted value an actual value and you
want to form the difference right and
just this innocent computation is I
think very hard to really to model with
no more realistic neural networks
because we heard this no kind of
inhibitor neurons are not just mirror
images of excited neurons they have no
different firing probabilities they have
different connection patterns and they
have also different types of short-term
plasticity of the synapses so therefore
you don't really have an exciting known
you can get inhibitory clone which kind
of produces the same thing just with the
negative sign as an output I think this
is really impossible to do with any
realistic neural models seems to be
missing one word make it impossible yeah
sir very good yes so the most important
word is left out there so make it
impossible to implement subtraction but
no my god yeah and so this is I think
mostly for me a kind of a kind of a
pointer to really know to pause and
think right now that we really have to
maybe rethink no computational design
then if you take this effects of
polarity the network's seriously and I
think it's a good chances that you're
blushing effects simply have chosen
quite different No
computation architectures and we should
discover them right we should not always
produce clones of NN architectures but
really no discover new types of doing
computations which are supported by
these types of data then and I want to a
little bit also I think this would
expect that speaks against is as I
mentioned typically if you have a
population say of exciter prison of
neurons in a particular type of say
excited every post in a big neurons then
the synapses tend to have all the same
type of shorter plasticity so although
it's changes know somewhat then in
prefrontal cortex it apparently more
facility in other choruses it's them to
be multi pressing then so it's not a
mixture of the pressing and facilitating
come from the same pool of pre and
postsynaptic neurons so therefore I
think this solution may not work out
actually so to mention I think this has
been reported also by Mansfield from
Amsterdam also for human neurons so that
they're depressing though they strongly
depressing neurons no synapses between
pyramidal cells in the human brain no
you have a neuron a in an artificial
network norm P you want to transmit a
message of firing rate right so now you
do it now with reveal synapse and so
therefore the amplitude of the
postsynaptic epsp becomes smaller and
smaller for later spikes in this spike
train so we want to use this rate to
represent the variable you don't have
any invariance right so in some sense no
synapse can no longer be characterized
by a single parameter it has no temporal
aspect and you have to attempt this
history dependence of the synapse has to
be taken into account then otherwise now
you have huge no kind of no deviations
from how this network should behave then
this is another thing I think one thing
is no rate coding is not possible
becomes difficult but also kind of
really in a producing kind of the
negative of a result kind of an hibbott
or a clone of a excited or noise I think
it's also impossible
I wouldn't know really how to put it
together with any new ones and synapse
types which are in the Ellen Institute
other I think one really has to sing us
and then about neural coding for example
I think one ideas is simply then excited
neurons to know each of them tries is an
expert whatever they fire they want to
give a particular message know they
convey content right then there are thus
inhibitory networks which want to make
sure that not all the time all this
neurons want to kind of know raise their
hand and say it's my content right so
therefore it's more regulation of
experts I think I think it's closer to I
think the very hub apology uses
excitatory neuron and inhibitory neurons
rather than the way how we use in
artificial neural networks we just know
any patient is just a negative of an
excitation then so I think no one
question about the quickly now ran
through is know whether what our neural
models which are Network models of
computation models which can and have no
a nor be compatible with this diversity
but we also can possibly even benefit
from this and I think now as I mentioned
also I think if I'm really wants to
understand biological neural chemical
computation one should sing in terms of
time series of no network states then
and I think one of the nicest no early
result boss no when they buzz in cricket
I think no in the children leptin in
Rome paper they gave two different
orders to this animal and so then they
recorded no I think on 87 ruins now
simultaneously and so these are three
pcs
of this no high-dimensional network
activity and see know kind of it moves
out here and then it moves back then and
then they give a different order it
moves out here and then it comes back
what's missing is know that this
trajectory of networks that it never
moves to a point an attractor which is
then by theoreticians postulated as
being the code for this particular order
right it keeps moving all the time then
and so this seems to be something which
is quite generic then whenever you look
then you have you ever find know that
the network state no space no fix really
put there no in the detector like no
baseness so they all just keep moving
and so therefore I think one has to
really entertain this idea and that now
when you look at no kind of no dynamical
system as a model for brain networks
know it has attractors and it has its no
trajectories taught subtractors that in
the end now this attractors are very no
transient and most of the time the
network is in this trajectories and
really computes in terms of trajectories
it doesn't compute in terms of no fixed
points then and so therefore this is a
different way of really not using a
dynamical system for computation then
you know I think it would be an
advantage if no one would know postulate
that an organism really gets as input
all of us a time-series an organism
never gets a [ __ ] input and always has
to reproduce output serious and not its
artificial know when you have to make
one output decision or when your kind of
animal has to decide all the time kind
of know flee or approach then right to
forage you know or not then so you have
both know kind of on the input side and
the output side are streams then right
and I think one should sing of the
computation engine being a filter which
operates no transformer input time
stream in a target output time stream
then but it's really on time server so
therefore I think mine can entertain
this this is just another computation
context of the brains then and doing the
multiplication also is really no kind of
a very artificial contrived kind of a
computational task then it needs some
kind of meta state that's derived from
that trajectory it has to know what
trajectory that it's a good point now I
think about come to the slides we see
but also fancy is no kind of in the data
for Mike Shetland that there are special
ruins which kind of integrate over
seconds no kind of evidence for or
against a particular decision I do have
no kind of move left or right and you
see no competing neurons no kind of
which each integrate evidence by the
rest of the network is quite active then
right so so therefore one season also on
one there are methods apparently how the
brain can transform a trajectory of
states into in the end of decision at
some time point then ya know invariant
you don't want it stuck on that one set
of neurons so you get tremendous
protection if you put it on some sort of
trajectory so that if pieces all those
places have to be calibrated so
with resident of one particular area
that puts a lot of stress on the model
to make to make that happen with living
whether it's just floating then it takes
the heat off something that maybe you're
arguing that there's some kind of simply
no system level benefit for having kind
of no representation moving around
rather than being stuck there no bad
difference fire for long time so I'm not
sure whether I should discuss it now it
you can look it up in the slides I
pulled out this slide here it's a result
from no Leon Chua who is here the
Faculty of ECS know had proven this very
nice theorem and it tells us I think
it's one of the very few theoretical
cells which says there is a benefit in
having diversity of computation units
then I think almost all results I know
is saying things get worse if you have
in a more diverse unit sense so this is
one result which suggests no in a very
constrained set up it's good to have no
diversity of units and so here no let's
quickly go through this then so it's
about approximating a given time
invariant filter with fading memory no
so this this could be also equivalent
the field are represented by Volterra
series there so not only the inner
filters but non linear filters so you
can approximate any such filter having
two types of Units here this is a memory
less output unit simply no kind of thing
about this is a kind of artificial
neural networks feed-forward nor without
any temporal operation but then it's
enough to have in parallel filter Bank
where each of them is a filter which and
all together this example has to satisfy
this point by separation property and so
this is a demand on the diversity of the
selection of filters because it says
when you have any two input functions no
on which this filter has to operate
which used to be different at some point
in the past there has to be some filter
in this pool which gives a different
output for this to function at the
current time step and obviously if you
wouldn't have this property no this
couldn't give different outputs for U
and V then right no because this is your
bottleneck no for the information about
the input time series is going to the
other
and so it turns out that this point by
separation property gives you sufficient
property for all this temporal
computation so when Caesar I'm kind of
principal piece together quite complex
nonlinear filters if you just have a
rich enough filter Bank then right there
no more the proposal that the biological
system isn't part of the filter Bank
right but think in terms of recording
rule networks may be similar effects I
used and I mainly not give this you know
want to show this here because I think
there's an open problem really a deep
open problem I think also for
theoreticians but the with computer
science irritation is can be provide
further an or theoretical insight into
having and the computational benefits of
having diverse computational units
within the network now this is not a
great example but I think is one of the
best I have found or the best even and
this is I think it's a nice open problem
so let's leave it there then there's
this theory of liquid no computing which
was mentioned which makes use of these
things now can algo but maybe I leave
out all these things then yeah I don't
know how it's proven you know
I think I don't want to go into all of
this then
yes maybe I think I mentioned only about
this liquid computing idea is that this
is one way of just doing computations
when you have is simply you can take in
off-the-shelf a network number which is
constructed according to the end data
database or so with having diverse rules
no very complex connectivity having no
synapses with different shorter
plasticity if you put enough of them in
there and then you train linear readout
from these no complex circuits to do a
particular computation this works no
typically very well then and so this is
probably the reason why this has become
such a popular model because it one of
the few things that works even for
spiking neurons even for very via types
of non neural models then and so the I
think I don't want to go further into
this then and I think no the only theory
that I know of no in the back way which
supports this is this theorem of poitain
schewe
which gives a little bit at least goes
in direction of supporting kind of no
benefit for of having diverse units then
so then there's also now here I have
some slides about what happens if you
add no feedback from the readout into
the back in the neuron and then
certainly the theoretical computational
power of this type of network really
jumps then so suddenly again you're no
longer stuck it filters with a fading
memory but you can even simulate any no
dynamical system formulated in terms of
a system of differential equation a
special case also editing machine
so this is something where a lot of
recent work also looked into this
question now when you train now a
readout which not just goes to
downstream networks but really project
is the readout value back into the
network then certainly you can also
practically no carry out no very strong
computations then answers it at the
moment quite a bit of debate then what
good learning algorithms for doing this
then and I think I have a slide No
yeah with discussing this recent
literature so you may want to look it up
so they're all about different base of
training to read out the feedback then
so there's this force algorithm which
process
post snow by Cecilia and Albert a while
ago just very recently Claudia Cooper
has shown that this algorithm can be
applied out to the network of spiking
neurons and really it's just practically
it's a method of generating non-trivial
computations in this networks and I
think that kind of the point where some
work needs to be done is that I think
none of this authors would argue this
force algorithm is politically realistic
so if neural networks or brain networks
use such a strategy they use also
different learning algorithms and so far
one has found if an has no this looks at
this in a context of artificial neural
networks one can also do this training
of readouts with robot more related have
been learning which is no reasonable
realistic from biological perspective
it's an open question whether also for
spike in neural networks the force
algorithm for training readers with
feedback can be replaced by a
biologically more realistic learning
methods and kind of a technical
additional challenge for all these
learning algorithms is August since you
have this feedback this learning has to
home in very fast a good solution
otherwise it's simply because it
projects its arrows back into the
network it simply gets stuck in bad
solutions to so here no it's really key
that the learning arizim kind of know
converges extremely fast a good solution
then and then there's a number of
experimental data which have principal
support no predictions of this type of
no liquid computing with diverse units
then so the fading memory property has
been shown then it's also this idea of
multiplexing of neural codes is
something which you know grew out of
this ideas and this has been supported
by a number of no exciting no
experimental studies and also know this
effect know that in principle you can
have a diversity of different readouts
which all get input from the same
coracle column but really do different
computations this also has been shown o
to some in one special case to take
place in cortical columns there I want
to move you know two other points then
rather because I think they're more
newer then and maybe also have more open
questions associated to them
and so bun is that really genuine
difference between what Siri predicted
now what should be the typical Network
activity for network of spiking neurons
which carries our computation so this
has been postulated that this should be
in the so called AI regime which is a
synchronous irregular firing regime then
which nobody here know this about no few
hundred neurons and so this looks like
no white noise then and if you add up no
the the rate some of the semi rates and
it looks like this then and this version
of kind of considered is the most
beneficial regime for a required network
of spike nodes to carry out computations
because the other ones had no kind of
oscillations or other artifacts which
were made then but now if you look now
it data when you have recordings for
many neurons at once so they sent from
electrode recordings from the Harris lab
then from a one area one in the road and
then you see this is time here one
second
so both spontaneously and with tone
comes and you see that there's certain
kind of population events then they call
this know typically Assemblies of
neurons then and then also what they
pointed out in this study here is that
this population events in both before
there's any auditory input and then all
inter inputs comes they were similar to
each other then which I think for me
looks like the first type of neural
coding you can choose for a you don't
let its nor no code something
independently but also you have this no
network activity stimulated by this
assembly activities and you find the
same assemblies no when there's no tone
and the same is almost the same
assemblies on average if there's a toll
so this is here one line for each neuron
and the red dot mark see on the time
axis it's preferred frying time on
repeated activation of this assembly
then you call assembly sequence so it's
always a little bit a time cause in this
is no case rather first time cause there
and I think about what we are missing is
in our computational model which can a
live where this type of neural coding
and B can benefit from this type of
neural coding and
I mention orally there possibly even
things about notes or stochastic
computation if a certain assembly goes
on
maybe I could view this no I sampling
that the local network states no
switches now to one or so by this
assembly is now going on then so this
could be just one possible
interpretation what dimension also the
same thing has been found now also
taking place in area v1 then even when
natural movies are shown then both
spontaneously and nor doing movies you
see very similar population events so
this was on used to live with calcium
imaging so therefore I think we really
have to know kind of face the fact that
what theory proposes as being the best
no activity regime of spiking neural
networks is not the one Nature has
chosen then right and I think we have to
retool really and Noorie address know
this existing data then and I'm somewhat
alarmed by the fact that these are kind
of all data but I think when I read no
Theory papers they still not talk about
this AI received in right so I think
there's a very slow kind of no
transmission of information from
experimental neuroscience or theory of
neuroscience and I think we have to
shorten this transmission time from some
like ten years to one year or less than
otherwise we are not making enough
progress then so here I have also no
kind of put together number of reference
if you want to learn about these aspects
there are a number of very nice no
papers which all of them address both
actually no extramental data of this
assembly activity but also some ideas
about the computational implications
from them so this particular no this is
a very nice it's a brand-new science
paper where they're proposed that no
assembly coding no forces is a certain
very clever hashing process which now
has a computation implication the other
types of no data and reviews which is
less the fact that possibly memory
contents are also encoded in the human
brain by Assemblies of neurons and
perhaps no crystal poverty Mitra will
discuss little bit also from the
extramental perspective and so I think
they're in the
in a rough no model would say also if
you think about no banana then probably
in the same day of neuron gets active in
your brain then and so therefore kind of
higher level thinking apparently takes
place in terms of activation and
deactivation of assemblies and what
they're missing is really a computation
calculus which supports this type of
computation with these types of encoding
there so let me also not talk about a
little bit of unexpected properties of
synaptic plasticity maybe have actually
no talk where little bit of the talks
were not really addressing much synaptic
plasticity I find this actually for a
serial modeling kind of the the most
annoying kind of lack of knowledge that
no there's a huge literature of synaptic
plasticity but if you take a close look
there's large diversity of results then
and Barisan on syria usually in the uses
one learning rule and just says this is
no universally used in the brain then a
version of the data i don't really
support this but the additional effects
known we have already heard know that
and on principle know there's the spines
no on [ __ ] no kind of axons numb from
synapses and now as long as soon as
bands started to be able to record from
the same dendrites and with kinds of
imaging over many days one found that
the besides no spines that are kind of
there all the time don't experiment
there's some which only there for three
days and go again another spine was only
present for one day and this is
something which is repairing the
inherent properties of spine because the
the kind of growth and shrinking of
synapses is according not to this data
also takes place if there's no neural
activity so it's a type of changes in
synaptic strengths then because spine
volume is a good proxy for synaptic
weight then and this takes place even
when here no
spiking activity about stopped here at
this time point and even becomes
somewhat larger there
so the appears to be a genuine molecular
encoded property of spines that all the
time kind of now have some dynamics
going on then and so this is apparently
one large factor in synaptic plasticity
one other aspect of kind of no onyx
property of synaptic plasticity really
emerged from two datasets one dataset is
really this data set from the least man
labna which they've discussed yesterday
they had some lucky cases where the head
you know the screen then right and then
here this blue exon which formed here
several synapses on the same dendrite I
think he even for then now when you look
at any learning role you see no this all
these synapses here this yellow synapses
they have the same prison happy knowing
they have the same person up in the wind
they even have the same person at the
dendrite right and it's very close
together I think this probably 50
microns or something of this far more
less than and so then they looked at
kind of what is a correlation in the
strengths of this synapses in terms of
in their data in terms of spine volumes
in other data said from culture from the
Sibley they looked at sizes of PS these
postsynaptic densities and they found
the correlation between the synapses is
there but it's pretty weak then right
now it's 0.23 then various I think the
common thinking about no synaptic
plasticity as a goal-directed learning
would suggest no the synapses have to
have all identical values except for
differences initial state then right and
so this I think is a puzzle there this
big correlation in the strength of
synapses which have the same pre and
postsynaptic neurons there and so this
is when some things will be a biast nor
could it also be indication for a
different strategy of synaptic
plasticity and possibly even have
benefits and so this is not about the
ethical framework that I want to quickly
go through know as the last component of
my talk then reason he also looked at
some data from the lab of sips so these
are cultured but there has advantage
they can image over 48 hours no kind of
know the sizes of postsynaptic density
so most specifically the number of PhD
95 molecules and so these are now here
pairs of synapses which have the same
pre and postsynaptic neurons and you see
that not only when you take a snapshot
now they you find different values but
even if you normalize them to one at the
beginning they drift apart and during
this 48 hours there
and so this supports this no kind of
hypothesis conclusions of this
extramental papers that synaptic
plasticity is only is to large extent
here's a blue area is driven by
spontaneous synapse autonomous processes
and these are those components of
synaptic plasticity which may be kind of
no run really by what we usually call
learning algorithms there so this is the
second level of plasticity right it can
contribute also to try to try
variability but this is a level of torus
asleep it probably takes place on a
slower time scale than right rather than
kind of notice firing plasticity and
know kind of synapses which don't
release which is enough noise on a fast
time scale this is seems to be noise on
a slower time scale and again the
creation is what could it be good for
there's a study I'm not sure if it's
that one is Christian Harris want to be
active on this one there was a fan base
in ops give us one author which also
studied this and arrived at a different
conclusion than claiming it's the same
so this is something no I discussed this
with non no I'm sipping and so it
discussed in their paper which was in
PLoS Biology 2016 so they argue that
they had used a much smaller data set
and of I think 17 or so of this past
then and also there had not ignored some
of the data then so this is a debate
among neuroscientists yeah I think the
strongest data set comes from Dishman I
think he had no it's in the supplement
of the 2015 paper I think it's the
hundred or so of such pair stand of
synapses which have the pre same pre and
postsynaptic neurons there and so this
is I think no apparently you could that
I said but I agree no them it's really
no kind of on the cutting edge of
technology right now these types of
measurements and we have to look out for
this
so yeah correlation between well this is
what I the bloody theoretician I would
say no they have the same learning rule
right and so if they start with the same
initial state no they should always know
kind of go in lockstep like a pilot but
the ultimate measure here is the
strength of the connection between those
two neurons and so you could just look
at the sum of those four synapses all
right okay this would be good there but
then we have to think about now a new
type of plasticity algorithm right which
organizes all this five to ten synaptic
connections between two neurons right
and the communication between this five
to ten synapses which are typically
apparently not on the same dendritic
branch then right so it becomes a
non-local non trivial learning rule but
certainly could also take place here
except I think what is the destiny I
think suggest to look at probabilistic
learning rules and I'd rather in
deterministic one every learning rule I
see in books until neuroscience or
papers is a deterministic rule I help
Delta W and then something no
deterministic there and so I think to me
the suggest not to look exactly no at
probabilistic learning rules and so at
that point like you get a very clean
distribution but it still be a very
holistic process I think you'll agree no
I think no if you look at the STP data
typically you have a nice STP curve and
lots of dots right and each dot is one
experiment and they're all over the
place then right so if synapse plays
different kind of no role then some work
let me also move on here to something
else then which i think is for those of
you who love neural coding as a firm
foundation for neural computation so I
think all the measurements which have no
really tried to track non workouts of a
longer time span
apparently the safe lap nor at Stanford
was the first one
they found note that their drift on the
timescale of days two weeks then so this
is here when this road and runs through
linear trek then so on day one you sort
them according to foreign times and when
they run again through the same track on
five days later no you no longer find
this right to find a new kind of no
linear relationship in the firing
probability if you reorder them no
according to the Frank time at day 20
when they run to the same track then so
apparently this places are shifting then
they are you can you can still no kind
of expect some invariant knowledge but
no the place code no they argue is
something which is drifting and more
recently of this paper from the Harvey
lab appeared this is in posterior
parietal cortex of mice then and they
have also kind of know an assembly
sequence no encoding a kind of a learned
to first choice behavior and they also
argue that no on the timescale of ten
days this quite a bit changes this
neural coat and and so therefore I think
this data suggests that neural coding at
least then higher parts of the brain is
not a firm foundation but it's drifting
right and so this is something which
also now should give us to think no
because how can you have invariant kind
of control in memory and now being able
to walk right now when things are
drifting in your brain we need to look
at series which can live with such
drifts then
I don't my goodness if the campus is
supposed to be involved in maintaining
and it's an episodic memory it goes back
in time excuse me something and in a
rodent that's supposed to be I mean the
number that sticks in my head is like
thirty days I mean after 30 days the
information that was trapped there
episodically
during you know he's gone
any human it's about a year and so
you're calling it a drifting
representation maybe you think it's a
representation being forgotten actually
I'm not calling this is what the author
causes then yeah well the other hand
these are not memories right now this I
think is having different no that rodent
runs through the same linear track then
so it's it's not memorizing something or
recording something really running
through the same linear track then and
so I think when hare story this no one
here no kind of fires for a particular
place on this first day and then no
longer fires for this place on this day
then so the place coding of neurons ants
areas here one is changing according to
the data so I think it doesn't have at
this points having to do with memories
episodic memory but this place coding
maybe let me also a little bit go ahead
in my talk then so I think you know
coming to a few open question then so I
think that we really I think this is RB
I think one of the most pressing problem
particular so for serial to kind of know
from the computer science how can be an
ends attain and maintain stable
computation function if everything is
changing then also on slower timescales
right now newer codes are drifting
probably synaptic connections are
drifting synapse synaptic debates are
drifting even if there is no overt
learning then and the question is there
anything invariant and so I want to hear
no sketches theory which in principle
allows us to think about something which
remains in Barren there and so
ya know looking at their the situation
which was you suggested but this young
man maybe look now at learning rules
which have a stochastic term so here no
this is now a learning rule tell you a
moment but it is but it has here kind of
an infinitesimal step of a random walk
and so this is now stochastic
differential equation or longer
differential equation or difference
equation as one usually uses that to
write down the plasticity rules it has
see a drift term which I discussed in a
moment and here diffusion term where you
have a temperature parameter which
scales how strong is this kind of random
walk aspect of this synaptic plasticity
the way in in this model know how this
parameter today I was chosen it was
chosen so that is both kind of controls
synaptic connectivity because no it's
it's used in this model so that whenever
theta is larger than zero then this
encodes functional synaptic connection
and in this case the exponent of this is
then the actual synaptic weights then so
this exponent transformation was just
chosen here because then one can write
down simply equation and feeding them to
data about this dynamic so here the goal
is to integrate rewiring and synaptic
plasticity changes of synaptic strengths
into a common thread framework and
learning rule now this looks like an
open equation here so by either way I
have plugged in something which is a
black box no if principal you can't plug
in here any distribution over Network
State so theta is the vector of all this
parameter theta I in the network and
here I have a partial derivative with
regard to the lock of some given P star
then now the fokker-planck equation of
tells us that if all this different
Taurasi equation for each nor i it
synaptic connection are running
simultaneously you can say something
about the station distribution of this
network now in terms of parameters no
longer in terms of network States but
parameter vectors namely it has unique
invariant station distribution something
which is very close to P star its
modulated by one over T then so
therefore high temperature its
then low-temperature no the peaks now
come out strongly then and so therefore
with this type of learning rule you can
in principle use this now as a a new
scheme for programming a desire no kind
of no behavior of network configurations
into the network where particular
network configurations are favored then
and I want to discuss you the case where
those network configurations are favored
where this network gets large rewards
then and maybe also some prior plays a
role here which expresses no you want to
have sparse activity for example or kind
of genetically encoded not literally now
this could be the connector memory that
certain synaptic connections should be
there no if not at all no overruled by
something else then and so then it turns
out no even really no fluxes into this
very theoretical answers in here once
instead then no if you look at the
partial derivative which arises here
when arrives at no in some sense
well-known rule for report gated a CBP
then here you have a legibility trace
whatever same as the peak event to clip
took place then it is kick the case over
time and RFPs are reward then so this
means that whenever reward comes recent
SDP kind of events now get kind of
engraved and but you have as a new
aspect here you have this stochastic
term on the learning rule and so
therefore this produces overall a
completely different picture of this
learning dynamics no you no longer can
think of a network of starting somewhere
and moving through a code configuration
and staying there it will keep moving
all around and write it network keep
sampling then even if there's no nothing
could be learnt and oh but I understand
that you know the induced diffusion you
may end up I mean you will go to a
stationary distribution but also
learning could make the
you change over time so there is that
I'm not sure birthing here not learning
learning is kind of know kind of doing
the sampling here there could be a meta
learning taking place that maybe after
by you know like when you grow older you
suddenly change your goals right now you
no longer care so much about money but
whatever so right and so this would
modify on the larger time scale of meta
learning possibly your state mr. Bush
but here the learning is part of no the
sampling here right this is this is a
learning kind of rule then in this model
then so let me also know I think robots
and you know dopamine is supposed to do
this and so we applied this as one taste
to very nice no kind of no data from
nature paper 2014 from the Kamiyama lip
where they had a mouse where the monitor
monitored many neurons there and this
was trained to do a complex lever
pressing tasks they first had to push it
down and then pull it up and then they
got a liquid drop of liquid then and so
they're needed know quite a number of
session to learn this so this is kind of
not checking here this movement over
time and you see after violin of session
14 now it becomes relatively still
typical and also know that checked here
know the the neurons activity so you see
no assembly sequences emerging them and
becoming cleaner then doing learning
then so they're neuron fires know most
of them fire only as a part of this
assembly sequence so this is a
consistent so with this data from Chris
hobby from post the parietal cortex that
apparently learnt behaviors encoded in
higher cortical areas like bridle cortex
and prefrontal cortex by assembly
sequences them and they also know they
are reported here no kind of no ongoing
spine activity no kind of new spines
coming on early when they were learning
started and later again elimination so
this it's to this pruning aspect if
yesterday mentioned also know that when
a new learning task arises then the new
spines new synaptic connections are
tried out whether they will be useful
them
so this something will be simulated in a
model and so this is now model which I
think in some sense is nice you know as
a discussion point now where they got
all this no results about diversity or
so because you know ya know working a
new regime we have simply can't put down
here model which is as diverse as you
want to a realistic as you want to you
can simply take off the shelf network no
from based on data from the institution
and so here know the only rule norm that
was or the only thing that was putting
structure into this versus learning rule
which is the one or robot based learning
group which are sketched then here and
so here no we kind of know mimic try to
mimic in a simple network model saw a
similar learning task so here the input
neurons simply gave a prompt then and
then there were two populations of
neurons and no activity in this
population the kind of pushes the lever
symbolic lever down and activity in this
push this lever up then and so then when
you start no not training now this
network it gets a reward whenever I does
this right no first pushing down and
then up then it gets a reward here so he
indicated by red and after no several
hours of learning it learnt this to do
this no quite efficiently and fast and
so nobody occasionally kind of failures
so so therefore one sees in some sense
you know this report based learning node
in this stochastic context can reproduce
on the level of no emergent network
computation these rails results which
were recorded then and one can also see
similar assembly sequences emergent I
want to address of an additional aspect
which now comes back to this stochastic
nature of the neural code also synaptic
Bates then so here we tracked now in a
three me the first three principal
components the whole network
vector theta so this is the vector of
actually not technically not all but a
large fraction of this network
parameters theta I so synaptic weights
plus synaptic connectivity then and so
at the same time drawing this trajectory
kind of the performance level
spluttered so we're learning starts no
performance completion time for this too
lever pressing task is long then it's
blue after about four hours it becomes
red then and then it prints away has
learnt at us but the network keeps
drifting around here so they're
irrelevant dimensions apparently of this
network connectivity and elasticity
which don't care for the test and he
would it serve the devious we could have
exchanged simply the role of this two
population so now activating here now
suddenly pushes the lever up and
vice-versa there so it had two
completely real and then but but what
happens here then in this boot is no
inherent aspect of the model you don't
have to tell the model now to start
learning again it will automatically
simply keep sampling then and now
there's those Network configurations
theta which give higher rewards for this
new setup other ones where it's going to
linger there longer than right so
therefore kind of compensation for
changing in the network or the tasks
then it's automatically performed by
this you don't have to put there a
separate kind of loop on top of a
learning algorithm which kind of now
says now we have to relearn then right
so this is something inherent in this
then and one aspect is also nice then
this is at least not qualitatively it's
consistent with this extra mental data
which I mentioned then on this strong
the strong friction of the spontaneous
synapse autonomous process which
apparently no usually enough I'm sorry
for this afternoon
so which usually no we can't really
interpret from the perspective of
synaptic plasticity or learning then
because if you look at Nam for which
type of for which temperatures this
network performs best including learning
fast and also relearning after this
drastic switch in the network we found
that this works best for intermediate
temperature which produce also a similar
amount of synapse autonomous dynamics
there meaning know where this T is
sufficiently large know to also produce
a lot of kind of not autonomous
plasticity so this can be seen as a
first week kind of link between this
extramental finding that the synapses
have their own going nor internal to
hatha dynamics and the model which puts
it in a proposed functional use then
because it's labels the network to keep
sampling always from new network
configurations to be optimally
opportunistic to see whether they're
better ones or particular also if it's
disturbed to come to a new kind of
better solution than so on no lifelong
learning in the sense is supported by
this but at the same time I think also
this simple model no kind of gives room
for the type of no ideas that they've
leased money as that I discussed no he
no discussed a lot no he's not thinking
that the connect home really contains a
lot of knowledge which Nature has
accumulated during evolution then and so
particular here and finds and this was
relatively small network I think 15
ruins or so and it took our snow of
simulated biological time to learn them
right so possibly one kind of a how you
know nature can enhance this is that for
really a current learning tasks the
connectome enables the network to faster
go through network configurations which
are likely to be good for learning
something that is important there right
so therefore here you can of course look
at this from a complete tabula rasa
framework everything can be learned but
their nature
no doesn't know no
kind of support no organisms which can
everything learn sometime but no fast
learning is a key than right and I think
critical interesting question of a
series to look at kind of connectivity's
which together with such no learning
models allow you fast learning and
relearning for limited range of
computation tasks and so this would give
a new way of understanding nor the role
of the connectome not it's something
that is fixed but really giving a kind
of a base level of network activity and
learning capability which allows you
then to explore variations around the
space level of network connectivity then
in principle also norm as you probably
have noticed no this not talking about
temperature we are here very close or no
there are powerful optimization methods
simulated annealing which guarantees
that in principle even decreases
decreases the temperature in according
to a suit sufficiently slowly then this
network nor has even a theory guarantee
to finding a globally optimal solution
so this I think an interesting question
whether nature uses such cooling methods
then so let me know the last five
minutes maybe talk about methodological
issues and I think we have seen or from
having not all this wonderful talks
about no which were driven by political
data and now here these considerations
which look at this data more from the
perspective of not getting Network
functional models out of this the
question of how to choose a model then
and I think know we should not become
more systematic about this in a
principle you all know no it's good to
choose simple models right sorry about
this so Newton was I think very good he
ignored know that there's friction also
in the air then right and then he could
no use Epis evidence for kind of know
the laws of gravity but assuming no
Newton would have decided now to
understand no the factories of Leafs no
but kind of moving around then right so
now the question then surely also no say
well you know been said not can ignore
vine right now I want to have simple
models it's just gravity right and I
think this is the question via in then
when we look at biological data and also
function of this models right now
computation function but aspects of
these models that we see are kind of not
yet essential for this particular no
tasks that be aiming at which bands can
be selected and if it simply looks at
literature I think no there's a very
strong bias thoughts of one particular
way of regularizing models for be an
instant one tends to use the
mathematically simplest neuron and
synapse models and I think this is a
tradition which is know kind of very
well justified in a simply form
tradition of mathematics and theater
computer science right you want to have
simple clear models and then you also
can have the nicest mathematics but I
think when we really want to understand
not be an end I think we need to kind of
consider consider also other ways of
regularized I think we need one way of
kind of weeding out models and avoiding
that we have too many models otherwise
they're overfitting right so we should
in the end have also smallest possible
pool of candidate models but I think you
know for example you could also use no
kind of as one regularization methods
know that you want to focus our models
that accept exhibit a similar bust net
robustness to network preparations
perturbations as below general networks
or mu use models that condemn us then
also use models that are consistent with
more experimental data about village
neural network 7seas even really now
look extend spec and asked what are the
options for regularization there's many
different ones and I think we have to
kind of discuss these options more kind
of know more consciously and most
systemically I think typically now when
you when I see in a paper into
neuroscience they have another simple
model and they say something is
politically plausible this is all no the
discussion about all of this I think we
it needs more than one sentence and
right now we simply look at the pros and
cons of choosing different models simply
look also also options for modeling then
and I think I would be in very nice in
if he also not doing this now coming
weeks we can discuss
some what are the right types of models
what are the options and in the end I
think it becomes more sign of material
science if we have also this
mythological discussion going on and we
can justify why we use this model for
this task that we all know there's no
ideal solution all models are wrong then
right we have to ask for what can I
expect from this model what are the risk
of really coming up with completely
irritability error about solutions in
this model right so maybe it has to be
more qualitative discussion then there's
also no kind of another kind of no
principled method firm at least
classified models was ready a long time
ago proposed MA and poggio so that you
have it know the abstract computation
level then the algorithmic level then
the implementation level and there's a
very long tradition of theoreticians
know of saying let's just think about
this then what needs to be computed and
what I could algorithm for this because
they are can use all the tools I am
familiar with and and then somehow
somebody else has to figure out how can
Pilates neural networks really implement
this strategy I think what my impression
is that now we have so many data early
about be intense that we have to take
this seriously and I think this I think
I have tried to show in my lectures that
simply taking this data seriously
suggest particular algorithmic
approaches and in the end also different
computational kind of approaches like
sampling or so which otherwise may not
be suggested if not suggested by
biological data so I think we have to
learn also to to take all the three
levels of this MA hierarchy seriously in
the recent paper know together with
Christus which emerged simply as a
preparation workshop for this brain 2018
we hadn't also try to collect the number
of references and also open pradhans
which particular could be of interest
for computer scientists who look into
understanding brain computation and I
want to give reference for this then
so my summaries that my person hunches
that the organization of computations
impedance is very different from schemes
that are familiar from computer science
and artificial neural networks there is
something to be discovered there they
discuss not also the impact of a few
aspects of biology and they make
specific suggestions also for
computational organization there's
another set of kind of nos additions
which emerges from what Bartlett
discussed and write which I didn't touch
upon it all then which again I think
suggest different types of organization
of computation and learning also so
basically if I do like a bunch of
learning the details of what would
happen to - do a bunch of learning one
sort of learning thing I'm not sure
where that it really no cares about this
right now this is here about a kind of
university would have to formulate bunch
of learning as a stochastic differential
equation if you don't have it to persist
elastic term you can't apply the
fokker-planck equation right it really
allows you only to analyze stochastic
moves like Nova's apparently invented to
analyze Brownian motion right where you
it's very hard to predict the trajectory
of a particular particle but you can say
what is the probability that there are
many particles over here then right so
if we look at this new kind of step back
then and look at this evolution of the
distribution of network configurations
know then you find loss then and it's
certainly I think it's it doesn't give
you as all the information you want to
and I think you're driving it no I think
a big point of this analysis because it
doesn't tell you how fast it converges
to the station distribution right this
is what it would need for fast learning
typically and so therefore again now you
kind of
productively maybe turn it around so
therefore we shouldn't look at the most
general Network right and the most
general learning rules but us know how
can you support fast learning of really
important tasks or so rather than being
a completely general then formation
geometry techniques that make this much
faster but you know I mean generally I
think my questions about the framework
you're you're really envisioning a
single distribution for the brain no I
wouldn't go so far now look look I'm
trying to look at models for brain
computation and learning no I don't want
to say no the brain is like this then
right I think yeah at least I feel be
much further back then right at the
moment I think we don't understand the
single thing about brain networks right
so I both be happy of really producing
at least know something which moves us
in direction of understanding
computation in brain networks but it's a
lot long way off then I think one should
be realize now how how far we are now
for me when Karen is actually know
looking at know Jeff yesterday suggested
this scientific you then right now you
get this data and we should also
reproduce this so for me I think when we
are able to reproduce really rich
computational and learning capability in
constructed networks of sparkin neurons
then we have understood something how to
work with these devices then right but I
think as far as I know we are far away
from this right so we a lot of kind of
no papers which argue no this fits to
this data but if you look at data
typically experimental data a low
dimensional so every kind of model with
many parameters can be fitted to a low
dimensional kind of constraints then
right so I think no there really the
evidence for current models being really
close to what the brain does is not so
strong in my view then and then I was a
knock diversity of brain
computation M brain area so I think they
are several I think behind you just just
curious for some context in some of
these are official spiking your in
neural networks like what how many
neurons are there
in some of these experiments so here now
this were a few neurons I think 50 or so
and so this Renault on our smallish
cluster now it was just enough for this
then so I think about scales is up to a
few hundred neurons when it's ready
pretty large computer then to Carosa so
I think maybe we're kind of getting
close not to a situation where at Google
or so know where you have large
computing capabilities you can explore
many of these models much better than we
can do with current smaller simulations
and my question is say I think you your
lectures gave a very good picture of
really what in neuroscience what the
observational data are and how they are
really challenging our models like the
drift like you know they've accomplished
10 days later the code looks different
and things like that but on one of your
slides there was also there was also
this statement you know for example long
from few examples and so I wonder how
much should we take constraints
seriously that really that we know about
behavior and what brains can do and for
example to take this seriously learning
from few examples that probably means
that we need to look at algorithms that
are kind of modular in a way that you
can take what you learned in one domain
and somehow transfer it to another
domain and so my question to you is just
to what extent can we also take
observation seriously that come actually
more from the behavioral side and in how
can this constrain our models and so on
I think I know it Pastner from the work
of no Josh Tenenbaum kind of who has
been saying this for a long time right
it'd be like artificial neural networks
drivers in the wrong corner we should we
understand how humans can learn
something from one example or few
example and so he argues that learning
takes place on several levels of
abstraction simultaneously right that
they are priors
formed for lower level networks and so
this is not addressed yet all there was
one kind of a prior somewhere in there
but one could think of this of maybe
being kind of here
prior even a kind of which is not know
drops from the sky but is no maybe also
learned on a more slower time scale or
also innate knowledge I think is really
I think an important question right now
how can he net knowledge something that
he put into the network really not
enable it to learn certain things very
fast and and I fully agree I think no
one has to take no data also behavioral
data seriously right I think not
otherwise no we are easily as
theoreticians now we have our favorite
games then right and be a carried away
by them if nobody pulls us back but I
mean you have to know something about
the brain triage to it so for example
when one shot learning you need a campus
or maple if you don't have those you
can't do the one-shot learning and
there's a beautiful recent paper on that
I think it's read a rat running on a
treadmill and it turns out the rent has
a different family class for visual
input that it may can predict that's
consistent with its motion and another
bus if it's inconsistent so the idea of
some very high level the raddest divides
the world into things that are
consistent with its own internal state
and things that are inconsistent and I
think it's a very important to have
these large scale economies on the table
to put situate the math in the right
place otherwise math is just gonna sort
of spread like a virus nothing more
general right now you mentioned this
hippocampus is doing certain things
right in ceará we always look at it in
your network of neurons right if we
don't even think about where it is in
the brain then right and so this is I
think really a defect right now they are
specialist brain networks right and
hippocampus is a special one where knows
a lot about and typically at least
coming from no abstract no serious so we
ignore this right now because maybe it
also hasn't been you know kind of
salient we made cell enough and concise
enough for us what us
kind of
difference in the computation goals in
the circuit organization in learning
rules in different areas than but I
think it's certainly no kind of nor
skeleton in the closet nor that we
always want to look at this generic no
net effects of neurons and I think it's
problematic just abrupt change of the
sequence because it's in a different
environment word statement is in the
next day so like some contact signal
might change to talk about this data
from the safe lab in Stanford so this is
from the C flipped and as far as I
remember them from the paper and his
talk then I think that tried not to do
anything drastic to then the rodents
right now they were just now put in
their homepage and then put back you
know every day on this linear track then
so of course now they have other things
they learn things right now and it could
be no this is dressage that they learned
in the same time probably they learned
other mazes in right or the homepage no
they have a separate map then right and
so they're kind of interfering then I
think contend is around also because
when we learning in look at network
learning in models or in theory you
always assume this thing has to learn
one thing and nothing else in right so
you could also say this is simply a kind
of consequence of having to learn many
different things and maintain memories
of update memories of many different
things right and so then you have
interference of this memory traces then
I'm glad you put that up because I
wanted to ask you about this before and
you've moved on this cell cell number
one and fires early on the track there's
a track here right that's what it is
so really in the track he fires and then
starts firing so this cell has a place
field in the track on on this day five
and that point on the track at day 10 no
longer activates that self nor 15 20 25
insider so what I said I want to talk
about this is a memory this cell is a
cell that responds to the cues that
somehow indicate that it's early in the
track early in the you know on day five
and later in no longer responds to those
cues so if it's a zit it's like a little
recognizing unit that has forgotten this
pattern that's how I interpreted
basically what's interesting about this
is that these cells as you look along
here there's hardly any activity of
those cells
anything this may be kind of an artifact
of plotting because you see him now here
they have reordered it according to the
order and which their fire here on on
this day then right and so here it looks
much mock tivity here then here then so
this is just something which I think
just comes from this color coat and I
mean yeah it really it seems to be
latched on to some other photographer
but that's kind of what an episodic
memory would do if it has a limited
capacity it fills up so it doesn't
understand okay are those the same
neurons and 15 is a day five in this
yeah this is what they argue in this
paper know is that the same neurons or
thing actually you know they're more
neurons in right so this let's see I
think it may be a different animal or a
different right so this I didn't notice
sorry about this you know order for day
five I think they just you can order the
recording date if you go to day 20 you
could
so as such the prior in the order that
the track you know that the animals runs
along the try so this happened to be the
cell fire first longer practice the
second third old even on day 20 and the
exact same cells 20 days ago they were
not organized in the same way on the
track or firing at all looks like you're
well it looks like they I mean if
they're the same selvedge they were
firing you just can't see it
right there just in a random order where
you just can't do it could be or they
may not do something out far along the
tracks
that's the question what is are these
the same cells amounted they're just at
a different order you think at least
know these are the same cells then right
and this all the same sir but I agree
yes in sampling sorry I didn't look at
this and yeah and so here this is at
least I think these are the same cells
maybe they do a certain selection that
they're here selected out of large much
larger pools of cells those neurons
which fire at a particular time on this
day right and so this is defines now
this 222 in ruins and and possibly you
know from the same pool that all these
things then it's just a different
mapping but we have to look at the paper
yeah maybe we should break and have
people continue outside
[Applause]